we are kicking off hispanic heritage
month this morning celebrating the
diverse cultures from all over latin
america that are right here in the
valley this morning we're profiling the
award-winning mariachi program at the
college of southern nevada hector mejia
joining us live from the campus in north
las vegas with this beautiful
celebration we have really just been
enjoying good morning hector
good morning heather the students woke
up extra early to join us this morning
and to show us a little bit about what
mariachi plateau is all about the
program been here around for uh this
group actually formed just a few years
ago and joining us live we have robert
benora fine arts department chair to
talk to us about the celebration that
kicks off here on campus tonight good
morning sir thank you
yes tonight is the kickoff for hispanic
heritage month uh we will be doing an
event from five to seven at the tyrone
thompson student center here at the
north las vegas campus
and uh it's going to feature
performances by mariachi plata um it's
our and first
exposure for
ballet folklorico at csn this is the
first semester that we've offered this
class you were telling me brand new
program brand new program it's three
weeks old so uh we've got community
groups we've got a bunch of community
resources we're trying to emphasize also
uh vaccinations on campus we have a
vaccination clinic for families we have
tequiro so there will be free tacos free
tacos everyone free tacos can't say no
to free tacos and not say no to free
tacos tell us about the group the group
has been in existence
like this for about three years and
already winning top national honors
absolutely we're nationally recognized
already and we hope to be going back to
san antonio in december to mariachi
vargas extravaganza um
and we hope to bring back more more
awards for csn that's uh that's the goal
right now
as chair of fine arts have you seen the
the program help students navigate
through school well it's just it's
getting the students inside the door
that's that's the important thing is is
we're trying to make sure that uh
especially the hispanic community is is
welcomed in and we're trying to make
sure that everything is that we're doing
culturally we're doing everything right
that we should be doing and this is just
another way to try to recruit for the
students to come in the door
and learn about and play some beautiful
music as well along the way absolutely
play mariachi and who knows they might
discover that you know
maybe i want to do this for a living or
do we offer over 200 degrees there's a
lot of choices of csn
and when we get the students in the door
we find that you know they they stick
and stay that's the important thing well
thanks for opening the doors early for
us before campus even started this
morning so we're going to let you guys
uh take a look here at the group and all
meet up with students here the
celebration tonight is free everyone is
welcome to attend and again it's
happening here at the csn campus in
north las vegas starting at 5 p.m
reporting live hector mejia 8 news now
back to you guys
and there they go hector thank you so
much what a beautiful way to celebrate
the diversity here in our community
there's some talent on that stage no
doubt this early in the morning
good way to wake up hey join us this
weekend as we share the stories of
people in places who've helped southern
nevada grow into the diverse community
that we know and that we love today our
hispanic heritage special airs saturday
night at 6 30. 6